[Musica]
Buongiorno a tutti
Fate partire le slide ok
È un piacere essere qui oggi pomeriggio
per parlarvi di un tema molto importante
Un tema attuale è un tema che come
Vedremo è molto più vicino a noi
rispetto a quello che normalmente
possiamo immaginare parliamo di spazio
ma non spazio nella sua maniera
tradizionale parliamo di spese economie
Ovvero della maniera in cui utilizziamo
l'infrastruttura spaziale per portare un
beneficio sulla terra per aiutare altri
settori vedremo che dallo spazio
aiutiamo settori come l'agricoltura la
medicina l'energia
settori tradizionalmente non sono
associati al settore spaziale
ma iniziamo con spiegare che cos'è
effettivamente la spesa Economy quando
si parla con un ingegnere con uno
scienziato con un politico ognuno dà una
propria interpretazione della spese
Economy e la cosa interessante è che
Hanno tutti ragione la spesa Economy se
utilizziamo questa definizione dell'oicd
include tutta quella serie di attività e
l'utilizzo di risorse che portano un
beneficio tramite la ricerca
l'esplorazione e l'utilizzo delle
Infrastrutture spaziale
una frase molto complessa in parole
semplici Che cosa significa significa
che noi utilizziamo un dato un servizio
che otteniamo dal satellite per aiutare
un altro settore
e ora vorrei che voi utilizzate qualche
secondo a pensare la prima delle due
domande che vi voglio porre La prima è
cosa vi viene in mente se io vi dico la
parola spazio proprio la prima cosa che
vi viene in mente
e quando io parlo con le persone spesso
a loro mi dicono pensate agli Astronauti
ho pensato ai pianeti alla NASA Lesa
elon musk spacex in realtà oggi lo
spazio è molto più rispetto a questo e
quindi pongo la seconda domanda
Qual è la differenza fra invenzione e
innovazione perché sono due termini che
spesso vengono confusi ma c'è una
sostanziale differenza fra i due quando
parliamo di invenzione stiamo parlando
proprio della creazione di qualcosa di
nuovo
l'innovazione ci permette di posizionare
Questa invenzione nel mercato e questa è
una cosa importantissima perché stiamo
parlando di spazio ma stiamo parlando di
Space Economy e la parola economia ha un
peso molto importante in questo concetto
e spesso viene associata il concetto di
Space Economy alla parola di spesa
Enterprise ovvero l'imprenditoria nel
settore spaziale e questo è molto
importante perché appunto non abbiamo
bisogno di inventare un nuovo satellite
di inventare un nuovo razzo possiamo
utilizzare quello che già sta volando in
orbita e utilizzare i prodotti i servizi
per trarne un beneficio diverso
e questa slide riporta il programma
copernicus Questo è uno dei programmi di
osservazione terrestre che ci fa proprio
capire come possiamo utilizzare i
prodotti spaziali per aiutarci sulla
Terra primo fra tutti vedete il
cambiamento climatico il cambiamento
climatico è un problema molto importante
lo conosciamo tutti ma come facciamo
effettivamente a monitorare il
cambiamento climatico e la risposta è lo
spazio Esistono dei satelliti che i
satelliti che sono appunto di
osservazione terrestre e che in maniera
continua prendono dati sul scioglimento
dei ghiacciai sull'innalzamento della
temperatura e forniscono questi dati
agli scienziati e poi epolitici per
poter prendere le decisioni che ci
interessano nella nostra vita quotidiana
ma il cambiamento climatico è un solo
uno degli aspetti parliamo di
monitoraggio del degli oceani
monitoraggio dell'atmosfera della terra
parliamo di sicurezza e di emergenza
questi sono due temi molto importanti
perché se noi pensiamo ad esempio ad
alpinisti o persone che fanno delle
esperienze un po' estreme Chiaramente si
possono trovare in una condizione di
difficoltà come possiamo aiutare queste
persone ed esistono delle Infrastrutture
satellitari per cui la persona in
pericolo lancia un segnale al satellite
che poi lo ripete sulla terra è una
squadra di soccorso può intervenire non
solo questo Ma pensate ad una grande
catastrofe ad esempio uno tsunami oppure
un incendio Come facciamo a monitorare
l'evoluzione di questo fenomeno
chiaramente non possiamo trovarci in
situ Perché sarebbe troppo pericoloso
utilizziamo l'infrastruttura satellitare
proprio per intervenire e interveniamo
in maniera attiva perché quando si parla
di monitoraggio non è semplicemente
capire come si sta espandendo l'incendio
o lo tsunami ma è capire dove arriverà
dove le persone possono essere salvate
chi dobbiamo evacuare e così via
per non andare troppo lontani quando si
parla anche di emergenza di sicurezza
Pensiamo a una cosa che ancora più
vicino a noi il covid il covid ha
completamente cambiato le nostre vite in
questi ultimi due anni ed è stato
necessario
creare un'infrastruttura che ad esempio
potesse trasferire dati in maniera molto
rapida in maniera sicura criptata da una
maniera da un posto all'altro non solo
questo ma Esistono delle aree che sono
un po' più remote dove manca il supporto
sanitario Come posso intervenire in
un'area Senza portare il medico e sono
stati creati dei sistemi che utilizzano
realtà virtuale e utilizzano
l'infrastruttura satellitare per
collegare delle zone che sono molto
lontane tra di loro e permettere
l'intervento di un medico
questi sono diverse delle sfere e che
vengono che traggono un beneficio
dall'infrastruttura spaziale e vedete
che è davvero abbiamo una grandissima
varietà dell'Agricoltura alla medicina
l'energia delle comunicazioni Smart
citys e così via
persino differenzia e sicurezza sappiamo
tutti della situazione che abbiamo Al
momento molto critica in Ucraina e una
guerra che è una zona molto una
condizione di rischio molto elevato
chiaramente utilizza anche un sistema
satellitare un sistema di satelliti
militari per aiutare per andare in
supporto quindi davvero tutti i campi
che vi possono venire in mente possono
trarre beneficio dall'industria
aerospaziale
conosciamo tutti gli sdgs il suo stand
Development goals ovvero degli obiettivi
di sviluppo sostenibile questi sono
degli obiettivi che sono stati stabiliti
a livello globale per aiutare la nostra
vita di oggi e la vita del domani
chiaramente non esiste un SG per lo
spazio Ma esiste lo spazio in servizio
ovvero utilizzare lo spazio per
migliorare abbiamo visto il cambiamento
climatico per migliorare il sistema
sanitario parliamo di Quality Education
parliamo di fame nel mondo Quindi tutti
elementi che utilizzano l'infrastruttura
spaziale
e questo è un grafico abbastanza
complesso che ho preso da brycetech e
rappresenta
l'impatto economico e nel 2021 proprio
della spese Economy come vedete
si arriva a circa 386 miliardi di
dollari americani e volevo farvi notare
una cosa importante vedete che la sfera
è divisa tre quarti è circondata da una
parte arancione quelle l'industria
satellitare e l'ultimo quarto è
l'industria non satellitare
nell'industria non satellitare troviamo
i budget dei governi e troviamo anche il
cosiddetto Commercial Human spaceflight
ovvero stiamo parlando di turismo
spaziale ora la prima cosa a cui
pensiamo quando
parliamo di turismo spaziale è la parte
un po' affascinante di sognare di fare
un viaggio andare nello nello spazio ed
è vero ed è una cosa bellissima ma se
voi Vedete tutto quello che c'è dietro
dobbiamo pensare a un'infrastruttura dal
punto di vista del razzi dobbiamo
pensare a una sicurezza dal punto di
vista medico psicologico si parla di
hotel spaziali Quindi vedete che ancora
una volta Ritorniamo al concetto di
economia dello spazio la parte
satellitare invece che tra l'altro
quella che un po' conosciamo un po' di
più perché la utilizziamo tutti i giorni
e includiamo la parte di televisione
satellitare I GPS c'è tanto davvero che
utilizziamo dallo spazio e quello che
viene diviso nel nella parte satellitare
è il cosiddetto spaceck mentre Grand
segment ovvero il segmento dello spazio
che include i satelliti e gli strumenti
e così via quindi tutto ciò che vola in
orbita
poi abbiamo invece la parte di terra e
quindi ad esempio i sistemi di
comunicazione le antenne e il
processamento di dati e così via
l'ultima cosa che volevo riportare qua è
il fatto che è vero che stiamo parlando
di Space Economy e di come e lo spazio
sta avendo un impatto nell'economia
globale Ma è anche vero il contrario
l'economia globale la maniera in cui
viene fatto il business l'imprenditoria
Ha un impatto anche nel settore spaziale
e qui ho riportato uno dei nuovi Trend
crowdsourcing credo che molti di voi
sappiate già di che cosa stiamo parlando
Ma in
parole povere questa parola è una
combinazione di crowd e Outsourcing
ovvero è la capacità di un'azienda di
andare fuori ovvero chiedere alla folla
al crowd di risolvere un problema per
loro e questo è quello che stanno
facendo anche le industrie aerospaziali
e in applicare qui ho riportato un
esempio della NASA dove viene messo un
bando e chiunque può partecipare ora Voi
potreste pensare ma stiamo parlando
della NASA Che cosa posso fare io per
contribuire a questa grande azienda ed è
una cosa invece molto importante perché
la NASA una fra tutte Chiaramente la
NASA sta utilizzando il crowdsourcing
pensate che un'azienda al giorno d'oggi
si sta muovendo in maniera molto molto
rapida Ci sono nuove tecnologie Ci sono
nuove applicazioni e se voi Pensate ad
esempio all'utilizzo di intelligenza
artificiale di Machine Learning È chiaro
che la NASA specializzata in un settore
spaziale potrebbe sviluppare alle
capacità di sviluppare degli algoritmi
molto complessi ma capite che
diventa un investimento dal punto di
vista economico dal punto di vista del
tempo dal punto di vista
forse anche umane e rischio è di perdere
rispetto alla concorrenza una cosa più
facile invece è andare fuori andare a
parlare con un'azienda che è
specializzata in un particolare tipo di
applicazione che può servire allo spazio
e potere così
avere una situazione che viene
comunemente descritta come un Win Win
ovvero vince la NASA vince
l'applicazione esterna per darvi un
esempio una fra tutti tempo fa ero ad
una conferenza e ho scoperto che nella
conferenza spaziale c'era uno stand
della Canon l'industria che conoscete
delle macchine fotografiche e ho pensato
ma cosa ci fa la Canon qui in una
conferenza spaziale ed è stata stupenda
questa scoperta che ho fatto perché la
Canon è riuscita a sviluppare delle
lenti che riescono vedere i colori nel
buio chiaramente nell'universo ci
troviamo in una condizione di totale
oscurità a seconda di dove ci troviamo
la NASA Chiaramente ha capito che è una
possibilità di Outsourcing quindi
prendere un
una un espertista esterna in questo caso
la Canon poteva trarre beneficio per il
suo business Dunque vi voglio lasciare
proprio con un messaggio e ognuno di voi
sicuramente lavora in un campo diverso
pensate alla difficoltà che avete nei
vostri cambi Qual è uno dei problemi che
voi Vedete ogni giorno e che vorreste
risolvere e pensate a come Potete
utilizzare l'infrastruttura spaziale per
risolverlo Grazie
Alla prossima
[Applauso]